good evening and welcome everyone to
this northwestern area
planning committee meeting and today
wednesday the 16th of june
my name is councillor maddie thompson
i'm chairman of this committee there are
just a few housekeeping issues to run
through
the setup of the meeting has been
designed to mitigate for covid and we
asked members to work to the protocols
agreed at the council meeting on 29th of
april uh
in the interest of member and office of
safety
the meeting will be streamed live and
recorded and by being present in the
meeting you're giving your consent to
being so recorded
members and officers during each item
please hold up your hand or your
paddle to indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
it actually says here the process this
evening will obviously be different but
actually it
won't be that different because i'll be
inviting members to speak in turn
just like we always do
but i would nevertheless ask and
encourage all members to keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible please
when invited to speak please remain
seated remove your mask
put on your visor and speak clearly
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph
number and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible i'll have
to delete that bit i've
said it item two is apologies for
absence casey
thank you chairman we've received
apologies from councillors jarvis and
keys thank you everyone else is here i
believe
item three is the minute of the 25th of
may
2021 um
it's recommended that they're approved
as a true of an act
as a true and accurate record they are
on pages seven to ten i so move do i
have a seconder
from someone who's here thank you um
can we have can i be those by ascent
members does anyone have any matters of
accuracy to
to raise okay lovely thank you
moving on then we have declarations of
interest
so i have to read this bit to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests
or non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
and members are reminded they're also
required to disclose any such interests
should they become aware if the need
arrives through the meeting
so i have councillor durham uh thank you
chairman a non-pecuniary interest as a
member of essex county council who are
statutory consultees
in areas of planning thank you thank you
and council fleming
thank you chair um a non-pecuniary as a
member of essex county council
as they are statutory consultees thank
you thank you so
much for any other hands up so we'll
move on
item five is land opposite
hall 34 hall road great totten
miss bowles would you please present the
report thank you chair
um firstly i do have a verbal update
following on from the members update
we have received agreement the
pre-commencement conditions
which are conditions 14 15 and 21 as set
out
in the members update
moving on planning permission is sought
for the erection of 30 dwellings with
associated access and landscaping
we've got the location plan which shows
the application site outlined in red
and the area of blue which is within the
ownership of the applicant but does not
form part of this application
we have the block plan as you can see
the site is accessed
from hall road with the first area of
public open space immediately to the
west of the access
plots one to twelve are located along
the eastern side of the
access road and there are the affordable
units
plots 18 and 19 are also located along
the
eastern side of the access road
plots 13 to 17 and 28
are located along the western side of
the access road just north of the first
area of public open space
the access road branch is off to the
west providing
access to plots 29 30 and continues
round in a
northwest direction to plots 19 and 28
and sorry it continues round in
northwest direction
with plots 19 to 28 set around the
second area of
public open space in a cul-de-sac
arrangement
i'm going to go through the elevation
floor of roof plans
of all the different house types and the
associated outbuildings
so we have plot one to four um which is
the
one bed flats and they are afford an
affordable unit
affordable units apologies
so we've got the elevations the floor
and roof plans
and then the associated outbuilding
we've got plots five to eight which are
two bed terraced dwellings
plots nine to ten which are
semi-detached three bed dwellings
and plots eleven to twelve which is
semi-detached two bed dwellings
plots one to twelve are the affordable
units
the remainder of the units are open
market dwellings
we've got plot 13 14 25
and 26 all the remaining plots they are
intermingled
around the site as detailed in the
committee report
we've got plots 15 to 17.
tear us three bed dwellings
what's 18 24 and 30 which are detached
four bed dwellings
plots 19 22 and 28 which are detached
four bed dwellings
plots 20 21 and 23 which detached four
bed dwellings
i've got 27 which is a detached four bed
dwelling
plot 29 which again is a detached four
bed dwelling
we've then got the proposed street scene
elevations
section a which is along the top
um is here between these two points
which you can see on the map in the
corner
section bb is the view between these two
points
and section cc is the view
between these two points
and we've got section dd which is here
the view from these two points section
ee which is the view between these two
points
and section f f which is the view along
the
the front of the site from hall road and
that single story
dwelling there is an existing
neighbouring property
we've then got some site photos just
looking into the site
and out through the access
and then we've got the dwellings which
border the site to the west
and the east and then some photos of
hall road
the application site has previously been
subject to an outline application for 30
dwellings which was refused by the
council
for one reason relating to the impact of
the development on the character and
appearance of the
area the decision was subsequently
appealed and the appeal was allowed in
march 2017.
although the application has expired
given that there have been no
significant changes to the site or
surrounding area
it is considered that this historic
application carry a significant weight
as detailed within the committee report
it's pertinent to note that the previous
application was allowed at the time when
the council
contended that it could demonstrate a
five-year house in land supply
which went unchallenged by the applicant
at that time
and as i'm sure you're all aware the
council cannot currently demonstrate a
five-year housing land supply
the council and planning inspector have
not historically objected to the
principle of residential development at
the application site
and it's not considered that there are
any justifiable reasons
to alter this stance the proposed scheme
is largely in line with the illustrative
layout submitted at the time of the
previous application
which was found to be acceptable by the
planning inspector subject to minor
changes which
have been addressed within this proposal
i have got a comparison
with the 2016 indicative layout this
side
and the proposed scheme this side
the appearance layout and scale of the
scheme are considered to be of an
acceptable quality which assimilates
into the settlement and be
immediately adjacent to the western
boundary of the application site
in addition no concerns in relation to
the impact upon residential immunity are
raised
the applicant has agreed to the planning
obligations set out in section 8 of the
report
and should the application be approved
these will be secured for our illegal
agreement
therefore the application is recommended
for approval subject to securing the
planning obligations and the conditions
set out within the members update
thank you chair thank you can we get the
clock up please
you're doing it thank you all right we
do have two public participants for this
application
um in line with the participation scheme
i'm going to invite uh objector with ms
sophie brownsell to read out her
submission
may i remind both of you i'll do you
both together
that you have two minutes only for the
public speaking in accordance with the
scheme
and those who know me know i stop you to
the nano second just to keep everything
fair to prepare for everyone
so please do use your microphone your
two minutes starts when you begin to
speak so make sure you're comfortable
and away you go thank you
the infrastructure is not suitable for
the additional 90 plus
cars this includes friends visitors
teenage children that may live there
traffic is already an issue in the
village and this would cause problems
during rush hour
school road and hall road are only
country lanes
and would not cope with that amount of
cars
the playing field in the children's play
park leads out onto school road
and would not be safe therefore for
children to cross
the residents who live on hall road have
lived there for many years
and their views and quality of life will
be disrupted
due to the building's works
the school and doctor surgeries are
already full
and they're fully subscribed and there
is a waiting list
if they need to travel to these outside
of the village
it would cause even more traffic
the natural wildlife will be a detriment
to the plan
to build more houses and this includes
plants and animals of many kinds
some of which are protected
as a mum of two small children i'm very
concerned about the level of toxins
in the gravel pit i'm also aware of how
any disturbance of the land could
release harmful fumes
into the area many older residents live
in this area
and there may be people who have
underlying health conditions
who cannot be exposed to these fumes
there would be additional pressure on
the sewers
this already floods during heavy rains
there are also concerns over flood risks
the plan increases the size of the
village beyond its current boundaries
which the village plan proposed sent out
in january 21
for residents consultation and approval
thank you thank you perfectly timed
okay now we have mr ford who is the
agent
same rules i know you know them so i
won't go through it again thank you
thank you sherman i'm russell ford a
chartered town planner and agent for the
application
you have a comprehensive report and it's
recommended for approval
now i'm planning permission for this
same development was allowed on appeal
in march 2017.
against legal advice this council
resisted the release of historic
covenants which was subsequently removed
by appeal
to lands tribunal a lengthy and
expensive process which took nearly
three years
that is why i submitted a reserve
matters application only in february
2020
your officers declined to register the
application and the original permission
lapsed
i substituted for a full application
shortly thereafter
which is the application before you
tonight it is in all respects reflective
of the original outline scheme
it is adjusted only in relation to
comments made by the appeal inspector
about how it can be improved
those improvements are present in the
current scheme and endorsed by your
officers
the application represents sustainable
development which has been acknowledged
throughout its lifetime
and so is supported by the presumption
in favor of granting planning permission
every possible technical question that
is in relation to contamination flood
risk drainage landscaping trees
residential immunity
nature conservation access and parking
has been asked and answered in this
proposal
all the statutory external experts agree
and offer no objection subjects
conditions
the proposal delivers 30 houses in
accordance with demographic need of
which 12 will be affordable
the council's housing officer supports
the proposal
all contributions that is relating to
education highway improvements
recreational disturbance and public open
space
have been updated and will be delivered
through a section 106
which is already drafted this is a
thoroughly scrutinized and well-designed
scheme
appropriate housing in the right place
and given the recent lapse in five-year
supply also
although belatedly at the right time in
these circumstances there is no reason
on earth why you would not support this
please please no more obstacles
recognize and commend the hard work that
has been done
including by your officers and grant
planning permission tonight
thank you thank you
actually you didn't fill the two houses
on the clock
um okay um
does anyone just for simplicity have any
questions of fact to ask planning
offices like
sizes and heights and before we actually
debate
right so i've got council morley and
councillor white
thank you it was a landfill site
have all the uh relevant checks um being
carried out on this site because i do
remember i think it's about 20 years ago
it was last used
but i got a feeling it was only for soil
i don't think it was for waste
well i know it wasn't it was i believe
there has been a contamination report
but i'm going to ask miss paul
elaborate on that yeah through your
chair um yeah
our environmental health department and
the environment agency have both been
consulted on this application
and looked at the contamination report
um there is
a few um conditions in relation to
contamination and remediation and should
any more arise
and those conditions should cover any
issues that might
arise through during the construction of
the development
thank you i'm just white
thank you chairman um no i i've got some
queries really um
the first one is under 5.911 um
there's no mention of a nature matrix
being carried out
to actually um advise on the
amount of um habitat that's being lost
unless it's just not in the report
and the other query i've got is under
policy e3 which
is shops um have we got i'm not familiar
with great tottenham
south um are there shops within easy
walking distance
um it's outside the settlement boundary
um
s1 with sustainability are there lots of
local bus stops shops doctors surgeries
everything within walking distance
and um the last one is i just wanted to
mention that there was an appeal
decision recently in my ward in pearly
and that previously had planning
application for one house and admittedly
they went in to convert some of the farm
buildings to make i think it was six
and the planning inspectors put no
weight on the appeal decision where
where it got approved first time around
um and um
so just to bear in mind that they they
do change their minds from time to time
this is true before i go to miss polls
mr fall could you possibly turn your
mind
off thank you uh miss balls of any
comment to make on that
or mr lee anybody yep through you chair
with regard to the accessibility of the
site it is within walking distance
of um a bus stop which is
very close to the site and i believe
there's a post office
within walking distance and a recreation
ground
so it is considered to be in a
sustainable and
location which is linked to um public
facilities
okay did i see your hand counselor yeah
you did chairman
thank you chairman um
we are
i mean we're here tonight due to a
technicality
um otherwise the the work would have
already started
on this as we know um and
you know we're between a bit of a rock
and a hard place and and i hear what the
the lady has said
um uh with her objections to it
but we have a previous in fact a fairly
recent
in in this great scheme of things appeal
decision
um and the only thing that has actually
changed since that appeal decision
is uh at the time that
that inspector made that um
made that decision we had a five-year
land supply regrettably
now we don't uh by a long shot
so actually we're in a far worse
position now than we
were defending the appeal back in
2017 um
so i i as i said we are in rather
a difficult situation on this and i
totally take on board the
the concerns but i um
the one thing i would like to just
clarify and
the officer almost answered it
um in in response to councillor morley's
question
um the previous gravel pit
the um the
reclamation scheme was obviously for
landfill
but can you just confirm that that
landfill was inert waste and building
rubble
rather than domestic waste
and through your chair if you just give
me a second i'm
cool there is a section on that in my
report
yesterday it was a leading question
because i have read it yeah
so paragraph 5.10.1
sets out um that it was industrial
commercial
it was licensed from 1979 to 1994 to
receive
industrial commercial and household
waste described as soil
none hazardous builders rubble soil and
excavator material
thank you chair thank you okay
council fleming and then council
thank you chair through you i just had a
question for miss bowles
i'm on page 15 3.1.12
uh talking about some of the plots
um your report details that yellow brick
will be used
for some of the market housing am i to
understand that the affordable housing
is in red brick and then also how does
that
then square with your comments in 5.3.16
policy h2 design and appearance of
affordable housing
is indistinguishable from market housing
thank you
through each hair i believe there is a
range of
materials being used on the site so
there's also render
um and other such materials like that so
it's a mix of materials it isn't that
all the open market houses are in one
material
and the affordable units are in another
thank you chair
thank you councillor siddall
thank you chairman as you know i
probably will have quite strong feelings
about this particular
planning application and the i have
great concerns
that this application and this site is
being built on something that we do not
know
what is buried in the ground so until
we're really sure
do we really want to take that risk and
build
houses on land that has been
contaminated by
as we've just been told industrial and
building
do we know where there's asbestos there
or not start immediately before we put a
hole in the ground
we should have a a a really really
strong
rigorous survey on this land before
anything actually starts
now the interesting thing about our
five-year land supply
the national policy framework states
that if we've got a three-year land
supply
then our policy and our local
development plan still applies
so therefore this particular site
should not be considered because it is
outside the settlement boundary
and it does have an extreme detrimental
effect on the countryside
on the site are lizard orchids
which are a protected plant so before we
do again
any work on this site we need to ensure
that all the lizards and all those
things are we have a check
that those aren't there anymore or
they're moved or they're protected
now i can understand the need for this
particular development i can understand
that
there is this element that we do need
houses however
i disagree with the with the applicant
because our own
housing department says that it does not
address the housing mix
so if you look at page 22 5.2.4
it does not address the housing me and
the balance
is not correct it is under the amount
that we should be allocating to this
site
so again that's a good reason why we
should be refusing this application
according to on page 23 on
5.3 according to our policies s1 and s8
the countryside and the protected for
its landfill escape
and natural resources as value as well
for its intrinsic character and beauty
so those things are not being addressed
by this application
other thing as well is on page 27
5.5.7 the rear gardens of plot
25 and 26 which
are semi-detached houses have a severe
effect on eight seven and nine
and nine millways uh and especially five
six and seven which would directly back
on to it i don't understand
in terms of the design and in terms of
the the landscaping and the way that
this has been designed
why where we've got these particular
houses
and again we need to look at this before
we pass it
why is it that we've got um
garages next to garages surely if we put
the garages at the rear of those houses
and move those houses to where the
garages are
that would then remove that detrimental
effect on those particular properties
it says in our report that the distance
considered to prevent signals that
is you know too light dominating effect
and overlooking
so therefore if we look at d1 we're not
protecting immediate surroundings we're
not
protecting accountancy there is
overlooking there is outlook
it's it's going to affect the outlook
and the light of those particular
property properties
so we can change that layout of the
houses to the garage at least if this
goes through
we are protecting those houses
the other thing as well on page 28 under
the level of private amenity space 5.7.2
it does not give enough immunity space
and again our officers say this in the
report that there is not enough private
immunity space
so i would rather see good design
and less public space for these
particular properties
so it's not good it's it's it's better
than it was 50
but it's not done in the right way
so the other thing i really don't
understand
is if we look at the diagram and we look
at page four the of the
the report or we look at the screen
bp between plot uh i think it's 18 and
12
there's a turning point now we've got a
design that allows for vehicle access
why is there a turning point at that
particular location which is just into
the site
the only reason that i can see that
there is a turning point
at that particular location is so that
in the future
the people who own this land can have
access
to the next fields which are still under
protection
so we have to remove that turning point
those are my points thank you i think
some of those are for you mr lee
thank you chairman i've actually got a
master i'll take it off if no one minds
um
firstly um my understanding is the
relationship to the three-year
land supply relates to neighbourhood
plans rather than to us as the district
and our ldp and that's a very big
difference because obviously
the mppf is very clear that the loss of
a five-year land supply
results in our policies becoming
outdated and
as members know when they're outdated we
are required to
deal with planning permissions through
the tilted balance which
puts weight in favor automatically of
delivering houses you know
that's why it's called the tilted bands
basically the scales are normally like
that
are now like this it's straight away in
favor of the applicant
and that is a consideration that we have
to give serious weight to the determined
authority we have to take these things
into consideration
um on top of that we need to take into
account all the general
normal material considerations that we
have to impact on caps
the area highways planning history etc
and as ms bowles explained in quite
detail there is a previous
outline planning permission granted on
this site
there has been a previous permission
at a time when we were able to
demonstrate a five-year land supply
so the inspector thought at the time of
the balance
the balance being balanced not tilted
that it was acceptable
to allow 30 dwellings on this site and
that is a maturation of significant
weight
what weighs even more faith in this
application is the fact that we now
no longer have a five-year land supply
and remember it's at 3.26 it's not
even just shy of five we are
significantly sure of having a five-year
land supply
so members really need to be conscious
of the principle
of this development is something we
would be very very difficult
to defend at appeal and put some very
dangerous position
that would be my advice in relation to
matters such as that
to echo what ms bowles explained about
the ecology
contamination issue there has been
reports submitted they have been found
to be
acceptable and we have though required
a number of conditions that require i
think slightly a bit of additional
information and protecting development
during the construction
this is standard planning process it
would not be
reasonable to refuse an application
because we do not know an entirety of
what is under the ground because
we never do and the conditions and the
reports they've submitted
should give us as decision makers
through the planning process
a comfort that there is a certain level
of safety
involved and that is the standard
acceptance anything above that
i think would be very difficult and puts
in a very difficult position
if we were looking to refuse it on that
um the point about housing mix i think
ms bowles covers in the report it
relates to obviously the history of the
site
we this was the outline mix that was
submitted it was considered acceptable
at the time
whilst the neighborhood or the local
plan has obviously moved forward
and obviously we have got policies that
try to
deliver the housing meetings according
to schma it's important to remember that
that policy is watered down by the fact
we no longer have a tilt
uh five lanes plan the tilted balance so
while
the need the smart the evidence is still
material consideration the use of our
policy is not as
robust as it has been so i think that is
not
forming a reason for refusal in my eyes
um the point about the intrinsic
character and beauty
you know my advice is that members is
that the inspector have found this site
can be developed for dwellings and there
won't be
a harm or a loss that is of a level that
is accepted is so detrimental that it
results in a reason for refusal
and that was at a time of a five-year
land supply once again and
you know we haven't got that similar
points in relation to garden
spaces mrs bowell's report obviously
explains that there are
a number of properties that are slightly
smaller than they should be
it's been officers consider that taking
into account
the five land supply where we are unable
to maybe be as
picky for one of a better phrase than we
normally would be in relation to matters
such as that
you know it's not considered to result
in advanceable harm to such a degree
it wants a reason for refusal um
and the points around the turning
circles garages etc
we're not here to redesign schemes we're
here to determine applications that are
submitted to us on whether or not
they're acceptable
you may think schemes can be made better
you may think schemes could be improved
but that's not necessarily
a reason for refusal just because it's
not perfect for one of a better phrase
if it meets the threshold which is our
ldp policies
if it crosses that line we need to
support the scheme and officers really
don't think there's any
objection in design terms and the fear
that a future
turning head could allow development in
the future is not material consideration
because that would be an application
that would be required
and would be assessed on its own merit
so the consideration that
a road could in future be used for
access isn't a material situation
terminated application
thank you chairman thank you you wanted
to come back council
yes thank you so it's interesting that
um
mr lee quotes our old dp and our
policies
when it suits him but not things when
i'm putting those particular points
forward
so can i have a yeah can can the
officers ask answer this question
is this a good design or does your
report
say that it's not a good design and that
there are problems with it
through you chairman i don't think
you'll ever does it so does the report
stipulate
that there are things wrong with this
design hannah does it state that
is he able to do that was yeah i was
actually addressing mr lee with that
it's hannah's report
i'd like to hear from you chairman i
think you'll actually find it's the
director's report
yeah um but i'm sure mr lee will let mrs
paul's
chip in if she feels an e would you like
to
work that out sorry sorry response
you want to say something oh i'm happy
too no right i'll pick that up
three chairman um
there are is it a good design that's my
question yes or no three chairman that's
the subjective opinion
well that's what planning is about
though planning is about subjection so
my subjective questions
not think please through your chairman
the planning act planning isn't about
subjectivity
it's about determining planning
applications in accordance with the ldp
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise
there are times that matters may be
subjective and design is one of them
and as i explained earlier just because
a design you think could be improved or
isn't perfect
doesn't automatically mean that warrants
a reason for refusal
you need to be able to show demonstrable
harm but further than that
taking into account the tilted balance
you need to be able to show
that the harm from the development is so
significant
that it outweighs any benefits
remembering that an inspector has
already found on a time when there was
no need to evidence that
that development of this site is
acceptable if members think that the
relatively standard design what we find
right across the district
is harmful that's within their gift but
you know and
but the point i would raise is that we
need to be showing that there is a
certain standard of harm that is much
higher than before we had the five-year
land supply so can i come back
you can but i must just say because of
the youtube recording we can only have
one member microphone at the time so you
do have to
yeah so it's interesting last week at
the
uh full planning committee we turned
down an application
due to the same reasons that i'm talking
about tonight
in terms of those plots that are
affecting the middleweight properties
uh that they are causing um
dimensionable harm to the properties
that are already there
and therefore yeah we we used that last
week in terms of turning down an
application
so therefore i see that we can use the
same reasons
that in terms of today's application so
there is we we know
that there is dimensional harm to the
properties on millway
and there is lots of light and there is
overlooking
and that is my main reason why i feel
that we need to turn this down
because it is not it does not fit a good
design policy
okay i actually have council fleming
then councillor darwin
thank you chair uh through you another
question for miss boles
um page 30 8.3
ecc initially raised an objection
i'd be grateful if miss boles could
expand upon that for
the committee thank you give us a page
number possibly
30 i think thank you
yeah the lead local flood authority um
they did request additional information
and additional reports uh which the
applicant did submit during the course
of the application
uh there was a bit of back and forth
which is why why this application has
been so delayed but the app
but the information has been forthcoming
essex county council withdrew their
objection and have just suggested
some conditions
thank you chairman um ms post do you
mind just
drilling down on what their concerns
were exactly
thank you i understand that they've the
applicants submitted reports but if you
could just
outline what what the concerns were
thank you through youtube i do believe
it was um the surface water drainage but
i will just double check that to make
sure it's correct
okay the thing is once
the flood also you know the flood
authority has accepted it
i've accepted it correct
teaching i'm glad just comment to be
honest it is not unusual for
essex county council's leaflet authority
to object
or put a hold in objection for a little
bit extra information
to be honest it happens more than it
doesn't
and to to be fair it's better that they
put a hold of an objection that they
then
removed and not put an objection and
yeah it chairman uh you know i have huge
sympathy with
councillors hiddles points and and um
and you know i i acknowledge the fact
that not
every aspect of this is perhaps as we
would
um ideally like it but i think the old
adage of
not letting the perfect be the enemy of
the good
comes in on on this to a certain extent
and
you know as as we've said before
whether we like it or not there was an
appeal decision in favor of this in 2017
uh very recently and it only ran out of
time by
um by arguably a
disagreement let's call it that or a
misunderstanding
and i think you know as i said i
i'm afraid i think we're going to have
to accept what is in front of us
despite the fact it may not be perfect
i think as with all these things it's a
question of degree isn't it i mean
do we think it's perfect no evidently
not very few
very few things are could we ask the
applicant and mr ford to
make some minor amendments and come back
with them or make some amendments and
come back with him
we certainly can but he doesn't have to
um well in the absence of a proposal
unless council still was going to make
one which i thought he was for a moment
there
then i i don't actually have any
recourse other than to put the
recommendation
which is to approve something to the
officer's report and the conditions and
so on
um help within that do i have a
secondary
you councillor morley um
for you chairman we'd recommend that was
through the members update
conditions rather than within the office
of report
this is true that's right thank you good
point mr lee thank you very much so we
should be looking up conditions
in the members update which should be
available
for you is there anything you think we
should
you should read out or we should hear mr
lee
chairman um there's slight tiding up
there was a numerical
ever in the original report we've also
amended a
food discussions with environmental
health and suds where
some can and can't be pre-commencement
and we've mr fooled as the agent on
behalf of the applicant has agreed the
pre-commencement conditions that are in
the uh
update um i think we'd better have a
show of hands because i suspect this
isn't going to be quite
a cent um so could we have those in
favor of the
recommendation please please show
so one two three four
five
that was against
oh sorry you don't get a vote if you're
not
good um one against
and abstentions is right
okay thank you so that is agreed in line
with the officer's recommendation
um thank you everyone for your
attendance um item seven is any other
items of business
the chairman considers are urgent there
are none
so with thanks to officers members and
everyone else um i close the meeting at
8
12. thank you can you please